>> Jon: I WAS BEING FACETIOUS,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THERE IS A BIG
CONVERSATION NOW THAT WE ARE
HAVING ABOUT CRIME.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: SHOOTINGS IN NEW YORK
CITY HAVE RISEN OVER THESE PAST
TWO YEARS AND ARE NOW AT 20%
LEVEL, I GUESS HIGHER THAN WHAT
THEY WERE SINCE THE STOPPING OF
STOP AND FRISK.
IT CAN'T BE THAT THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN CONTROL SHOOTINGS IN
NEW YORK CITY IS WHAT APPEARS TO
BE AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
ANGERING PROGRAM OF STOP AND
FRISK.
BUT THIS APPEARS TO BE A REAL
THING.
>> LET ME SAY IT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY.
WHEN BILL BRATTON CAME AS OUR
COMMISSIONER, FIRST PRESS
CONFERENCE HE SAID IN TERMS OF
STOP AND FRISK, YOU CAN'T BREAK
THE LAW TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> THAT FROM THE BEGINNING WAS
THE TEMPLATE WE TOOK.
SO CAN YOU DRIVE DOWN CRIME
WHILE RESPECTING CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS?
ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE MY FIRST
YEAR IN OFFICE, BILL BRATTON'S
FIRST YEAR AS COMMISSIONER,
CRIME WENT DOWN FROM 2013-2014,
THE LOWEST NUMBER OF MURDERS IN
N EW YORK IN 50 YEARS.
>> Jon: I GUESS YOU'RE SAYING WE
CAN DO BETTER.
>> WE CAN ABSOLUTELY DO BETTER.
>> Jon: WE CAN KILL MORE
PEOPLE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU MISINTERPRETED.
THERE'S BEEN A HORRIBLE
MISUNDERSTANDING.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> WE BROUGHT DOWN MURDER TO A
RATE SINCE WE'VE NOT SEEN SINCE
THE EARLY '60s.
WE BROUGHT DOWN CRIME ACROSS THE
BOARD.
WE DO HAVE A SHOOTING PROBLEM,
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
NOTHING LIKE NEW YORK CITY HAD
15, 20 YEARS AGO, BUT SOMETHING
PERSISTENT PARTICULARLY AROUND
GANGS, AND WE HAVE NEW
STRATEGIES TO GO IN THERE BOTH
WITH AGGRESSIVE POLICING BUT
ALSO GANG INTERVENTION, WHICH IS
THE PROCESS OF UNDERMINING GANG
RECRUITMENT AT THE THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL, WHICH HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
WORK ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THOSE STRAPS NEED TO BE APPLIED.
GOING BACK TO AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ALIENATING
APPROACH IS NOT ONLY UNFAIR AND
INAPPROPRIATE TO THE POPULOUS,
IT DOESN'T WORK.
IT TIES UP TIME AND ENERGY INTO
THINGS THAT AREN'T SERIOUS
CRIME.
SO WE'RE BROADLY ON THE RIGHT
TRACK.
WE'RE RETRAINING OUR POLICE
FORCES TO WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMUNITY.
WE'RE DOING BODY CAMERAS, WHICH
W ILLINSTILL MORE CONFIDENCE
WITH THE POLICE AND
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE PROVIDING MORE TECHNOLOGY
TO THE NYPD SO THEY WILL BE MORE
EFFECTIVE.
THING THESE WILL ADD UP AND
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT WASTING
TIME ON UNNECESSARY AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL STOPS OR
LOW-LEVEL MARIJUANA ARRESTS
EITHER.
>> Jon: WITH THAT I WOULD BE
ON--
BUT HOW DO YOU BRING UP THAT
MORALE -- BY THE WAY, IS A POUND
LOW LEVEL?
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, BECAUSE YOU HAVE
COMMUNITIES WHO BELIEVE THE
POLICE FORCE DOES NOT RESPECT
THEM AND TREATS THEM LIKE
THEY'RE AN OCCUPYING ARMY IN
AN AREA, AND THEN A POLICE FORCE
THAT FEELS DISRESPECT OR
FEELS LIKE THE BAD POLICE
OFFICERS ARE BEING USED TO
TAR THEM IN A SYSTEMIC WAY.
HOW DO YOU BRIDGE THE GAPS IN
THE COMMUNITY SO PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE BOTH BEING TREATED
FAIRLY WHEN, YOU KNOW AS I DO,
THE MINUTE MURDERS AND SHOOTINGS
GO UP POLITICAL PRESSURE IS
GOING TO BECOME IMMENSE, GET
THIS OUT OF OUR SIGHT.
PEOPLE DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE
IT'S NOT SAFE.
>> WELL, I THINK THE GOOD NEWS
IS IN THIS CITY WE HAD A REAL
THOROUGH DEBATE, AND PEOPLE DID
VOTE IN FAVOR OF CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND RESPECT FOR
COMMUNITY, WHILE HAVING STRONG
POLICING.
THERE'S NO DICHOTOMY HERE.
IN THE END A SAFER CITY IS ONE
IN WHICH POLICE AND CITY HAVE A
POWERFUL, STRONG, WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT ENCOURAGES A
COMMUNITY TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH THE POLICE.
POLICE OFFICERS WILL TELL YOU
THERE'S POLICE IN EVERY
COMMUNITY, LAW ABIEWDING PEOPLE
WHO KNOW EXACTLY WHERE THE
WEAPONS AND THE BAD GUYS ARE.
WE WANT THEM ON THE SIDE OF THE
POLICE AND THE BOND BETWEEN
POLICE.
WE FIND AS WE HAVE BEEN MAKING
OUR REFORMS AND BRINGING POLICE
AND COMMUNITY BACK TOGETHER,
WE'RE SEE AGO DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIP.
WE HAVE A CIVILIAN COMPLAINT
REVIEW BOARD, COMPLAINTS ARE
DOWN 25% FROM A YEAR AGO BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO MOVE PAST
SOME OF THOSE DIVISIONS OF THE
PAST AND ULTIMATELY EVERYONE
WANTS GOOD AND DECENT POLICING
AND POLICE WANT TO BE PROUD OF
THEIR PROFESSION AS THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO.
>> Jon: ARE THEY BRINGING MORE
COPS, YOU KNOW, POLICING AREAS
THEY'RE FROM AS OPPOSED TO
COMING IN FROM OTHER --
>> ABSOLUTELY, POLICING AREAS
THEY'RE FROM AND THE OTHER
VARIATION IS COMMUNITY POLICING,
APPLYING THE OFFICERS,
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY'RE
FROM, APPLYING THEM TO ONE
COMMUNITY LONG ENOUGH TO DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS AND GET TO KNOW
THE COMMUNITY.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT CREATE TRUST, MUTUAL
RESPECT, THAT KEEPS COMMUNITIES
AND OFFICERS SAFER.
>> Jon: THE OTHER THING THAT
BOTHERS ME, THEY WANT TO GO TO
END OF THE LINE OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN BUT NEVER WANT TO DEAL
WITH, YOU KNOW, WHY AREN'T WE
DOWN IN FLORIDA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
GEORGIA WHERE THESE GUNS ARE
COMING FROM AND STOPPING AND
FRISKING GUN STORES?
WHY DO WE HAVE TO WAIT AND
SOMEHOW PUT IT ALL ON
COMMUNITIES WHEN THE TRUTH IS
THERE IS A GUN-RUNNING OPERATION
THAT IS GOING ON IN THE SOUTH
THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT, BUT
NOBODY WILL IN ANY WAY ADDRESS.
>> THIS IS A FIGHT WE HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE IN OUR COUNTRY.
ASK THE LEADERSHIP, THE NYPD,
THEY WILL TELL YOU A SINGLE GUN
RECENTLY CAME OUT OF GEORGIA,
RECIRCULATED FROM CRIME TO
CRIME, USED IN VARIOUS SHOOTINGS
AROUND THE CITY, ONE GUN.
>> Jon: I'VE HEARD OF THAT,
THE ZIP GUN PROGRAM.
(LAUGHTER)
YOU GET THE GUN, USE IT FOR
A CRIME AND OBVIOUSLY BRING IT
BACK AND SOMEBODY ELSE SIGNS
IT OUT.
>> VERY SOPHISTICATED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: IT'S ABOUT RESOURCE --
BUT AGAIN, THEY KNOW THIS! AND
THEY KNOW THE PLACES THAT ARE
DOING THIS, THEY KNOW PEOPLE
THAT ARE DOING IT BUT THEY ARE
UNABLE TO -- FOR ALL THE
SURVEILLANCE AND INFORMATION WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU'RE
TELLING US YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
THE STUFF IS COMING FROM AND
WE CAN'T STOP IT?
>> IT'S A POLITICAL WILL
QUESTION.
LOOK, IF I WAS GOING TO THINK
ABOUT THE BIG STRUCTURE OF HOW
TO GET PROGRESSIVE CHANGE ON AN
ISSUE LIKE THAT, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET TO CREATOR UNIT AS A
NATION ON AN ISSUE LIKE GUN
CONTROL TILL WE DEAL WITH
ECONOMIC REALITY FIRST.
I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED WHEN YOU
GET TO PROGRESSIVE ECONOMICS,
YOU WILL UNIT PEOPLE ACROSS
REGIONS AND DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND FAITHS AND THAT
MAY BE THE BEGINNING OF A MORE
COMMON POLITICS AND COMMON SET
OF VALUES THAT SOMEDAY MAY LEAD
TO THE REALIZATION THAT PEOPLE
WHO WANT THE RESPECT OR THE
RIGHT TO HAVE A FIREARM, THAT
DOES NOT HAVE TO EQUATE WITH A
SITUATION THAT LEADS TO FIREARMS
ENDING UP IN OUR STREETS,
KILLING PEOPLE IN THE HANDS OF
CRIMINALS.
THAT WILL TAKE A LOT OF
TRANSCENDENCE AND WORK, BUT I
THINK ECONOMICS IS THE MOST
UNIFYING FORCE.
>> Jon: IS THE WAY TO DO IT,
THEN, TO SAY WE HAVE TO CREATE
ECONOMIES WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT CAN COMBAT THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMIES IN THE COMMUNITIES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jon: IF I'M 10 YEARS OLD
AND I HAVE A CRAPPY PANTS AND
SHIRT AND SEE SOME OTHER KID
THAT DOESN'T, I WILL BE OFF
AND THINK, THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
OUT.
YOU HAVE TO FIND AN ECONOMIC WAY
TO COMPETE WITH THAT TO GIVE ANY
HOPE TO IT.
>> THAT'S IT, EXACTLY.
WHAT HAPPENED IN BALTIMORE, PART
OF IT WAS POLICE COMMUNICATIONS,
BUT A LOT ECONOMIC REALITY.
IF YOU HAVE A COMMUNITY OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RARELY SEEN
CONSISTENT ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY,
YOU CANNOT BE SURPRISED IF THAT
COMMUNITY IS IN MANY WAYS
DISCONNECTED FROM THE LARGER
SOCIETY AROUND IT.
IF PEOPLE DON'T FEEL A SENSE OF
ECONOMIC HOPE, UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S WHERE CRIME BREEDS, WHERE
GANGS BREED.
KIDS THAT KNOW THEY HAVE
OPPORTUNITY AHEAD ARE MUCH LESS
ATTRACTED TO GANGS.
ONE TIME I WAS IN THE SOUTH
BRONX AND A FORMER GANG MEMBER
SAID SOMETHING SIMPLE TO ME.
HE SAID RECOGNIZE THE FACT A LOT
OF KIDS IF THEY'RE CONVINCED
THERE'S NO HOPE UP AHEAD THEY'RE
NOT GETTING TO COLLEGE OR A
CAREER, THEN A GANG LOOKS
ATTRACTIVE, LOOKS LIKE A FAMILY
AND A HOME.
WE HAVE TO SHOW YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE IS A WAY FORWARD TO A
DECENT FUTURE.
>> Jon: THIS IS THE SAME
CONVERSATION WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HAVING ABOUT CALTIMORE 40 YEARS
AGO.
LIBERAL AND DEMOCRATIC POLICIES
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE IN THOSE
AREAS.
THEY WERE SAYING THE SAME THING,
WE HAVE TO BRING THE AREAS HOPE
AND OPPORTUNITY, AND YET --
>> WELL, HERE'S THE PROBLEM
THAT WE JUST DEFINED A MOMENT
AGO.
IF -- PEOPLE HAVE BEEN GOING
BACKWARDS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN FAMILY
GOING BACKWARDS.
IF YOU'RE IN A POOR COMMUNITY,
THAT'S HITTING YOU HARDER.
WAGES HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
COST OF LIVING.
OPPORTUNITY IS MORE CONSTRAINED.
WE'RE IN THE STRONG GROWTH AREAS
IN THE ECONOMY, WALM-MART AND
OTHER PLACES THAT PAY A VERY LOW
WAGE.
SO, NO, WE HAVE NOT.
WE'VE INVESTED IN CERTAIN
PROGRAMS, SOME WORKED BETTER,
SOME WORSE, BUT WE HAVNE'T BUIT
AN ECONOMY THAT'S ACTUALLY
INCLUSIVE.
>> Jon: WHAT'S NICE IS IT
SHOWS IN TERMS OF ECONOMICS.
THEY TALK ABOUT TRICKLE DOWN
ECONOMICS.
POVERTY TRICK ALSO DOWN, NOT
RICHES.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING FOR A LONG TIME AND
THAT'S WHY ADDRESSING INCOME
INEQUALITY HEAD ON, TALKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE CURRENT
POLITICAL REALITY IS JUST NOT
WORKING IS WHERE WE'LL FIND A
BREAKTHROUGH.
>> Jon: THEN YOU WILL FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO STAY --
>> I SAID INCOME INEQUALITY NOT
HEIGHT INEQUALITY.
>> Jon: SON OF A BITCH.
00:09:14,954 --> 00:00:00,000
(APPLAUSE)